y llegamos a santiago la capital chilena
para hablar con nuestra periodista
patricia alguna patricia la salud o la
salud o muy buena mañana del lunes vamos
a hablar primero de las reacciones que
hay en ese país tras la victoria en
colombia el izquierdista gustavo petro
no
buenos y fríos días desde santiago raúl
así es el presidente gabriel boric muy
aficionado a usar twitter fue uno de los
primeros en manifestarse y en felicitar
tanto a petro como a su vicepresidenta y
en señalar que esto es una alegría para
américa latina que trabajarán unidos en
los desafíos del continente en un mundo
cambiante y veloz posteriormente
cancillería también emitió rápidamente
un comunicado en el que desea éxito al
nuevo gobierno de colombia señalando y
valorando positivamente el proceso
democrático de los colombianos su alta
participación y señalando que se va a
trabajar por una américa latina unida
compartiendo los mismos valores por su
parte la oposición no se manifestó sobre
este tema recordemos que petro había
sido uno de los invitados especiales en
el cambio de mando de gabriel boliche el
pasado 11 de marzo patricia vamos a
hablar precisamente de gabriel boric del
presidente que hace poco también
nosotros lo cubrimos en directo de lo
que fue su discurso ante el parlamento
de ese país en valparaíso patricia cómo
han sido estos primeros 100 días de
gobierno de boris otro líder de
izquierda elegido también por estos
deseos de cambio en medio de la fuerte
posición de la derecha tradicional de
nuestros países
unos cien días marcados por luces y
sombras como cabía esperar problemas de
instalación que fueron reconocidos por
las propias autoridades en el balance de
100 días que dije nos sin embargo
valoraron positivamente que ha habido
desafíos que han sido 100 días intensos
pero que se han conseguido avanzar entre
las partes positivas de estos primeros
100 días se destaca el acuerdo de escazú
que firmó un boris como uno de sus
primeros
una de sus primeras disposiciones al
tomar el mando que fue refrendado
también por el senado recordemos que
piñera se había desmarcado de este
acuerdo medioambiental que supone la
protección de sobre todo los líderes
medioambientales y entre otras cosas el
incremento del salario mínimo que subió
de manera significativa en uno de los
más grandes en los últimos 20 años y
también medidas medioambientales como la
decretada el pasado viernes que ha
causado mucha polémica en el país donde
se decretó el cierre progresivo de una
de las fundaciones de cobre en una de
las llamadas zonas de sacrificio
mandando el mensaje de que se ponen
primero a las personas y no a la
economía estas son algunos de los
aspectos positivos en un gobierno que
también ha estado marcado por temas
negativos